we can't hear you guys
no is it just me or anyone else can hear
there no I can't and they don't hear no
no it's okay yeah okay it looks like it
might even be a toast I can see the
little bars going red every time I talk
okay well welcome to this week's Android
developer office hours it turns out
there's a mute button on a microphone
and I just pushed it whilst trying to
get a microphone out of shot to reveal
these lovely think Android car here
instead is not just an Android driving
it I'm Richard Hyndman and I'm joined
today by Chris Bane's developer programs
engineer thanks for joining as an all
this will be a Android developer
discussion and we won't be making any
product announcements talking about
roadmaps that sort of thing so please
don't ask we will be taking questions
from and also the comment stream for the
Google+ post welcome to everyone who's
joined us in the Hangout a few familiar
faces again there
thank you all joining if you want to say
hi we got you'll see there hey yo C hi
guys
Vibha from Holland next hammer right one
of the founders of the dutch android
usergroup as his lower third is saying
leonid I believe works with Yosi yeah a
new one means do first time on our on
our show yeah good see you again hey
how's it going hi really good thanks
yeah and it's Ali on the end there hi
there good to see ya
are we just discussing before we went
live not
so much happening in the Android world
this week after CES finished last week
we've we've had quite a quiet week-long
January a bit of a yeah slow January
Nick's not with us today so we've been
joined by this Android who drives his
own car around
believe it or not yeah Android we have a
whole fleet of these things now they
race around the office and scare people
especially my job and run the office
right yesterday
it's using the idk to to move or is it
simple I don't know a remote control
system as you know but also it's got
pedals and steering wheels and stuff you
hopes going old-school yeah racing
around so this is our Nick butcher for
the week if you have any questions
Watson wrote it yeah okay yeah let's say
hey Andrew nice to see you again
I saw the one-man moderation machine put
plenty of questions in the moderator for
us this week again ok so let's kick off
does anybody in the Hangout have
anything they'd like to talk about or
any questions yeah I would like to raise
a question about using the ProGuard I've
run into some issue with the after we
added some loaders to the simple
application we're trying to do as a POC
first of all to see we're using loaders
and basically we wanted to do pro guard
on the loaders also and every time we
use the loader even though we're using
the second I'll open it even though I'm
using the keep class with members
classifier for the poor guard I still
get a verify error for the specific
class
anyone ever got this error I didn't see
anything on stackoverflow related to it
so I wanted to know if anyone was able
to use loaders fully with fragments and
action bar and everything
yeah program support Lib loaders all
native support ones and you get a very
fly around yeah I get java.lang fair
fire so god with that question straight
away yeah yeah sorry because we do
recommend using program of course it
reduces the footprint of your
application makes it more efficient yeah
I can do some great stuff there was a
really good talk from Eric the man
behind pro guard at droidcon UK this
year you can look it up and watch it he
did give some hints and tips during that
talk have you had a look at the video
yeah basically I just wanted to make
sure if you ever encounter something
like that because what I found and what
LO need also found that some problems
with using fragments based on the action
bar Sherlock and loaders and obfuscation
but no one actually gave us something to
work with only just I saw an issue and
it was resolved and interesting anything
I can cite is to not using their classes
and try implements a common core buckets
but um and with a callback on your
fragment or activity instead
so you ProGuard shouldn't really touch
it as long as you set an exception for
the method so I try and do that instead
and say we still see be still get the
verifier you shouldn't really but i
don't i without sort of looking more
details
yeah i can't expose all the code yeah
so because basically it's something
we're trying to build as new features on
our app yeah it's difficult to to put
them all together so does anyone else in
the Hangout have any thoughts on
ProGuard was this specific use case for
brogard as you said you could raise a
question or an issue over at
tools.android.com the ProGuard
integration is managed by SAP and
towards team over there yeah I'll try
over there also and I'll try to posted
again on Stack Overflow something yep
and pay me a link to the stucco flow
Freddie Norman okay waiting Thank You
Hugo said if you tried it without the
optimizations turned on yeah
optimization turned off turned on yeah
including in libraries keep optimization
on all there is you name it okay so we
can't be of more help on that one I
haven't pro guarded too much not too
much point because I'm a projects for
open source any other questions from
inside the Hangout Before we jump to the
moderator question I was wondering about
the two native apps the phone app and
the People app mm-hmm so with the phone
app and the people have to list views
that load lists of contacts yeah it
looks like the People app does something
similar to there's an Android training
that does a bit loading bitmaps
efficiently and if you think you guys
actually give a a demo I think it's
called bitmap fun yeah and it handles
loading bitmaps efficiently and it looks
like the People app does something along
those lines but the phone app
if you look at the list of contacts
there's like some list that the bitmaps
seem to be cast or they're already
they've already been stored in cache and
at any time you leave the phone app and
go back in it's not like it retries to
grab those maps yeah though is it yep is
it doing something different huh yeah it
probably is the phone app is a high
priority I'm guessing it's always
running to actually answer the phone
calls so maybe it's just keeping this
list in memory okay yeah I mean the
source is available so you can always
have a look through if you yeah it's
probably catching them anyway even if
you reboot your phone and have a look
are they all there as soon as it opens
up mm-hmm
so this apps starting up from booth
catching all the photos that it needs to
and just staying there it would like
there as soon as the Buddha the most
priority one of the priority things -
yeah I imagine that's the case I mean
I've never seen that the phone app would
not be running
I'll see if you can see it inside the
all the running apps because something
like it grabs all the names and the
numbers without basically without any
hiccups I'm scrolling yeah
like everything's completely cached
I doubt the name and number is that
that's just doing am content Friday
query
yeah but probably it startup I mean I
know the learning the bitmap is the
expensive operation
well yeah be it depends where you
learned it from me all the images on the
contacts will be on local storage
somewhere so yeah local storage it's not
like from the network
exactly so it'll be quicker anyway all
load in milliseconds rather than seconds
and so most of them are but there could
be some linked with your social accounts
but even well even the social accounts
they still have to put it into the
content provider and the cobbler avoid
the contacts content rather saves the
files oh yeah okay
and so if they've always local mmhmm
yeah actually I've got them to load so
it is starting on startup if you go into
settings you can find one called
phone slash messaging storage and you
can force close it and if you do that
when you're next if you force closed
phone and phone messaging storage and
then go back and load the application
you can see all the icons start to load
again okay so it's the launching on
startup it does request the boot on the
boot off startup permission launch so
yeah it looks like it's just starting on
startup and doing the exactly the same
thing to cache the data at that point
than staying yeah you know trying to
display some list similar to that do you
think it from a design perspective do
you think it's a big hindrance to have
to every time load those images each
time without saving it to cash to
something on hard cash every time to
actually cool them out of the yeah
context completely what I'm doing is
clearing the cache each time the app is
killed
yeah the problem is if you don't do that
when someone changes the contact photo
you're not going to pick it up are you
so it's a good idea to do what you're
doing and then reload them from the
content provider okay
so just because it's not loading at the
same speed of the phone app doesn't mean
it's not doing it efficiently because
I'm I'm doing it this similar way the
bitmap fun demonstration yeah I would
say that's fine they are cached on the
disk and you're just loading them
through the content provider anyway so
re cashing them a second time on the
disk isn't going to help too much yeah
it's the same storage so making
difference if I know because you'll be
probably saving two SD card or external
storage whereas the contacts provider
that's saved on your data storage and
which depend on the phone might the same
storage or might be slightly slower so
sounds like you make doing it perfectly
on your way I would stick with what
you're doing okay sounds good what are
your guys who's the speed maybe you
could catch the first couple closer but
I said he wouldn't catch the whole list
yeah okay all right
anyone else we're inside the Hangout so
I'm just looking at the chat window
Bieber Andrew Kalley it was posted hey I
have a question about the asynctask okay
I have some problems that I as a method
of doing background not not involved in
invoke when just in the task execute it
so I found some some post that when you
work with SDK a horny cop and above you
need to do execute on the executor and
not only execute a so the question why
we need to do it that way
um there was a very good explanation of
this in a talk at droidcon Holland this
year Vibha did the droidcon taught us go
live no no just wait until those toilets
got a life because there was a change in
the way that asynctasks
does work through gingerbread honeycomb
and Ice Cream Sandwich and if I remember
it correctly
gingerbread was stringy tasks and then
on honeycomb it changed so it's a
there's anyone Fred run at a time yeah
and because that's when we saw the
multi-core processors coming in and apps
were getting responses to async tasks
back in an order they weren't expecting
so we had it single-threaded to make
those apps work again but then Ice Cream
Sandwich and we defaulted back to
multi-threaded again unless you specify
single threaded so you can either way
you can specify and the best thing to do
is definitely to specify an executor and
say whether you want it to be single
threaded execution of all the async
tasks or a multi-threaded execution so
though no problem is on in there on you
come I I think there was another case as
well it's changed quite a lot I'd look
at this look at the Javadoc it should
tell you the differences and I'm just
looking now can you put some a link
those that explanation yes I will
we're just looking at the async task
Javadoc inside the Android developer
documents at the moment okay but it has
been on Stack Overflow a number of times
as well so the thing to do is definitely
specify an executor anyway we definitely
recommend that and you can guarantee
with your either your thread full
executor or your executor whether you
want it to be single threaded or
multi-threaded across all of the
versions of the OS okay thank you but in
Hugo's place djenka has joined instead
hater
and John was going with a picture of a
laptop okay so we grabbed a question out
of the moderator then I also got a
question so I gave a presentation on
about expansion files on droidcon
Amsterdam and yeah it was pretty cool I
gave it after first having played with
it and now there is a customer and he
wants an updated application but he
wants to keep using the expansion files
that we upload for the previous version
of the application I updated the stuff
that needed to be fixed and now I just
want to test if the new application
works with the old expansion files or
the previously uploaded expensive of
files
mm-hmm when I try to do that on my
Samsung Galaxy S which is a pretty
ancient phone I guess I I do get the
message saying that the expansion files
were downloaded even though when I
browse to the file browser and look at
the location where the expansion file
should be there is no expansion file at
all have you got any tips on that do you
do you know where I should look at now
we definitely re-upload the expansion
files when you change the apk always it
always a reload yeah I can check with
the publisher site team here but I've
heard some inconsistencies before and
it's just a good idea to upload the
expansion files we've had it before that
apks have been uploaded and then the
expansion files weren't being downloaded
things because they weren't associated
with that apk okay so I should just try
and upload it again and see if that
works yeah yeah you may be downloading
an empty expansion file if there's
nothing that science about apk and then
that's why you're just seeing a blank
space on the SD card okay in the next 20
minutes I know it'll take two hours to
go like Anton yeah it will take a while
yeah yeah all right well thanks I'll
give that a shot and
yeah alright pingas sonic google+
because i'd like to know the result just
to check that that didn't fix the
problem well do you know what thanks
very much
hey hello hey beginner in programming
and then college here needed we studied
this he short but I really kind of like
preparing Java for Android and give me
some advice I could build very good
Android apps
sorry we missed one I missed one word
another do I have to get something to
build very good Android apps I have to
do I have to be a Java program - yeah
guilt definitely helps if you know your
Java design patterns and you know how
the Java models work it can help make
better Android applications but you can
definitely start off with simple Android
applications without too much knowledge
of Java I mean all the UI layer of
androids done without any standard Java
in it really yeah more the websites the
videos and then they can give me a good
start mm-hm
yeah I wish Nick was here instead of
this pink car with a green and really
because he was a developer for his sins
at some point and switched over to Java
slash Android so he may have been able
to help with a migration for you yeah
definitely I would just get stuck into
things I would just start coding Android
and get used to it and then as you come
across probably assume that they've
already been sold by someone else and
look them up on the internet if you want
to figure out how to do a certain design
pattern in Java just look it up
sometimes are slightly different for
Android anyway because the way
activities work so yeah two integer into
Android as we know thanks for me right
no problem thanks for joining us in
there
yeah I'm drew Kelly has put a question
in the chat window right if I have an
intern service as the interface to a
rest service what is the best way to
have the intent service pop up and to me
progress dialog on the UI while the rest
call is asking do I need to use a
broadcast receiver oh I don't like
getting feedback from intensive and I
always think of intense M is a one-shot
deal it's sewing for you and yeah
exactly it's not something you want
feedback off or a callback or anything
like that and so the way I'd personally
do that is do it normal service and then
run your background query on a
background for an executor and use a
handler to make sure a dialog which
feels kind of hacky from a service but
you want to do form activity really and
so yeah if you have an activity that's
banned to the service yeah exactly you
can request the progress Google i/o 2010
gave a talk on using intern service as
something for rest but as clients for
rest yeah that's fine but then showing
the activity on the screen did it cover
that during the presentation and I think
any way I can think of that work nicely
he is if that intern service is updating
the content provider
no I didn't yeah and your and your
activities or Stasi getting read queried
and the contract pod changes I send you
nice well I can think of using inter so
it's that kind of stuff this is another
good case for that async task talk that
was given a column because it actually
covered all types of background
processing on Android and when to use
each one it was an amazing talk I took
notes from it might still happen here so
as soon as that go live I think I'll
just make sure I don't think that talks
will be going online - fair enough
no he did put the slides online I seem
to remember the slides did go out so we
could look up the name of a talk
do you think you could find it Vibha I'm
looking right now the guy who yeah gave
the talk we can find its light and just
post them in because it answered two of
the questions here in a lot of detail
give me five minutes I'm not good at
multitasking
execute a thread thread execute execute
Bieber's brain back it's not rescue it
would have been a more funny joke if I
could actually say it okay I'm just
gonna have a quick look in the G+
comment so what rich is looking Pavel's
put a question on the moderator asking
with data storage and the SQL like API
hadn't evolved since Android 1.0 is
there any chance to install alternatives
some is similar to the core IP I know us
there's nothing plans from I know and
from what what's available the moment
all I can do is point you to sort of
libraries that build upon it so you've
got green Dao which works pretty well
got om light there are paid solutions as
well and so just look at their mod if I
was here when the dow solutions cannot
perform with penalties but they usually
worth it just i remove a lot of
boilerplate code from your author you do
have to write basically and so it's
always good so yeah have a look at them
and let's know anyone else got any
questions
everybody's doing searches on that yeah
okay
so he's done good on Google+ not really
someone's asking how to join the hangout
which is just answered and then they've
got a question which they'll ask if they
can join a hangout so if Jackie does get
in check about the question life if not
I'll wait five minutes for answering
that question just in case and Michael
has put another question on the
moderator asking I heard about an app
that claims ik is able to back up data
from other apps and well will be able to
restore it on the device I thought this
is impossible without root access what
your thoughts on that I thought it was
impossible well if it's on the SD card
yeah that's the only way you could work
it might be reading the data directory
off the SD hey Jackie there you are
you found the link good to have you in
as well because the data directory for
each app has the permission set so only
the application can access them so I
don't really see how that's working
unless they're using a shirt intense and
share permissions basically if you have
like you have to share with a briea that
could be installed in the world no I
mean like if you have a set of
applications from the same side they're
using the same certificate and same
permissions so they have share
permissions to back up all the data and
to access all the data between all the
or all their apps yeah besides that but
yeah but besides that each app has a
private location for their for their
storage only if they used to if only if
they use the SD card to save all their
eggs RF currencies and stuff but even
then I think the new users API will
block
the access to the to the SD card and
basically get a virtual mapping for the
SD card for each user so I don't think
an app for backup will be helpful on
those devices I'm trying to find the
question in the motor rates and see
Austin it's multitasking more now Holly
already asked a question so the one
about the app that can do backups you
know about the expansion files okay you
heard that one as well though who asked
the question about the backup apps see
that was paper as well where is it on
the wrong day here it's a 16-4 process
just so you got a lot of devices we have
to use them all I have Michael Michael
pancit Michael Panzer I heard about an
app that claims uh yeah oh the app is
called carbon all right Jackie B
question yeah sorry uh yeah I was just
curious I'm working now on can you hear
me first of all yeah so I'm working a
lot on trying to do some porting of some
native applications and it's kind of
something I'm new to and I'm having some
difficulty getting mate to work right
with the standalone tool chain do you
have you guys had any experience with
that do you know I I posted I've read
through the documentation a little bit
for the standalone tool chain there's
some environmental variables or talks
about the setting but I was just curious
as to you know it's kind of hard to tell
it's working or not until you know you
go through and check out the objects
that get created but do you guys know is
there a good resource for this
the thing I mean it mentions in the
documentation that the st. alone
toolchain was made specifically
something good used make but I don't see
much documentation on how to implement
it with me personally I have no idea
because I've never shot a C++ developer
I see
I'd recommend posting your question on
Stack Overflow because that's all the
sort of native questions off go on there
really and so that's probably when you
get we go gonna get you most exposed and
probably answered yeah you can have a
look at tools to Android calm again and
have a look at the documentation that's
over there you know look at the forum a
tool start android.com as well and post
a question in there maybe because then
one of the tools team here will take a
look at it at least especially if you've
got a specific error that you're seeing
okay sounds good yeah it was more just a
generic question on getting me to work
with the standalone tool chain I just
I'm having I'm not very good with me so
I'm trying to figure that out
the only other time I have built smoke
vent the NDK is when ye i use the
command then dkb old rather than make
and not actually called make itself i
think for my remember so right i have a
look that maybe I'm using mate because
I'm trying to port over existing sea
library is like basically I'm working on
tutorials to be able to you know use
box2d and OpenGL ES and C and then use J
and I lookups to kind of communicate
with it and so I'm trying to rebuild
box2d just on my own and I'm having some
problems getting it to build with the
make scripts that come with it a fan NDK
build actually calls make itself so I
currently is that details but you create
a special make file and you can then
include other make files from it so you
may need to do some that like includes
your the custom make file and I don't
really know that it's pulling the depth
up my memory here I just figured I'd ask
thank you that yes and whilst you're
answering or asking that Viva did post
the presentation the Droid couldn't an
elf presentation in the chat window here
I hope this isn't a good one the correct
one is it on toes
I'm gonna see if I can just quickly
cross post it into the it's about
Android training that's one yeah
just bear with me a second I can't find
my own hangout now that I'm actually in
this is crazy if you could cross post
that after per hangout comments fever
that'd be very handy I already did
excellent thanks very much so anybody
who has questions about async tasks and
background services there were two of
them so far it's definitely worth
checking that presentation out cuz it
okay we have any other questions inside
the okay spec is all you need to do a
rich heritage a key okay Michael Panzers
put the link to that app that claims to
be able to do backups just you know to
see but it's alright it's from push for
start from clockworkmod syntax an app
data between phones backpacks your SD
card Google Drive check the video app
requires hundred four plus this is a
birth Peter
this requires route it says this is the
final version doesn't require yeah right
now Android are just clockworkmod no I
think maybe it's based on the clockwork
mod or maybe it's using the device
administrator features for Android 4.0
and basically then you can access
everything you want on the device so
because I didn't see the permissions
when I installed it or something yeah as
you can see see Super User on the video
and then Oh is using the full restore
ADB backup and restore yes he's using a
command-line shelter adv yes for
non-root so it's not actually running it
on the device at that point which isn't
a bad thing I mean ADB backup and
restore is very very powerful very handy
and I use it all the time for keeping my
game state data when I reflect my phone
which happens more than it should do
most users would never think about doing
that even developers are run rightly to
plug it in to a computer USB ADB backup
because you can actually securely back
up all your data your SD card and
everything through that and then restore
all your app data again so if someone's
writing an application which uses the
functionality of ADB backup and restore
but makes it more user friendly and
that's kind of Awesome yes it is allowed
it's not breaking any of the security
Ronald no is using the Google Drive to
basically save your data as a backup
file and then they can you can log in on
a different device and have the data
back from the Google Drive to your
device so whether he is I mean at
Mundy's you run a shell script to get it
working by plugging it in so whether
he's going to manage to sideload
something onto the device which means he
can do those backups without it being
plugged into a computer if he could that
would be awesome I'll read through the
rest of the threats like any client on
the phone there isn't when the final
version comes
I will definitely try it because there's
plenty of games that I used I'd love to
have the game day to synchronize between
all my devices even mine so just quickly
run this application to restore my
latest or backup my latest data or even
have it scheduled to do every time cool
oh good
whatsapp it there in the chat window
yeah it's J's question which of a sort
moderator and I think we're better to
add an animation progress method into
animation listener so the more
operations can be performed to an
animation is running and a question why
you're changing we're trying to know why
an animation is going and surely when
you start the animation you'll know that
it started so I can't I'm not sure why
you want to know how far into their
motion it is or you shouldn't really be
changing the view MIT and Midway for
animation because just causing more
worth digi-fuse GPU so no it isn't my
question why you want to know basically
you know when it started saying it yeah
it's ugly and how long it would take
oh yeah oh yeah did you call that so
oh it's Jason who's writing
I'll share the screen just a second to
see to show you the
that's the ADB that's the screen you see
when you type in to be back up yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah that's what
he uses basically to back up each and
every application then the data is being
uploaded to the Google Drive account for
the specific user so you sorry yo Cee Oh
awesome
that is calm but it's a video of carven
right that you're not running on your
device at the moment right no no no no
okay I just want to know whether it's
doing that without needing to people I
did there's a review of it over Android
Central as well that was posted on
Monday based on basically when I look on
the notification bar on the top I don't
see the devices connected to anything so
yeah it still says even from Monday the
Vita still requires root access the
final version should be non rooted
button no one's seen it yet so watch
that space I guess sounds quite so I
think it does J's put reply on I need to
update the layout from mister animation
progress and using the handle that it is
more code changing electrons der
elimination oh yeah I'm not too sure and
that will I question why you doing that
you know doing why should you do that
during your animation unless you want to
trip change objects on your animation
well while it's raining yeah if you need
to change the light crumbs during it
during an animation I would use a
handler and do it that way
using the post and then post keep
posting yourself until well if you're
going to have an on progress update
literate and they be using a handler to
send those updates back to the UI thread
anyway so whether you use a handler or
we have a method that uses and/or it's
it's going to be the same and yes
fair enough there's extra five lines of
code that you need but they should be
problem
all right Michelle from Denmark I'm
sorry for pushing magnet and it was
reported that the replies for review
option was being rolled out to more
developers about a week ago I'd really
like an official word on this as it's a
much-needed feature yeah it is a much
needed future and it is still being
tested so I think it was quite public
that the initial test group was the top
developers it's not being rolled out at
the moment to everybody hopefully it
will be at some point if the tests go
well and the feature is used as the team
are expecting to be used and all that
sort of thing and we may be able to
announce more at some point yeah it's
any it's a great teacher 17 all 17
questions thinks they're excellent and
there's nothing else appearing in the
hangout chat so if I know just posting a
question on the Google+ okay Grauman's
okay let me just refresh it and see what
comes up got a quick question from
Jefferson wrote about widget provider on
update the docs say that app widget IDs
may include all the app widget instances
or just a subset what's the criteria
which instances are included in the
array have a look at the source now it
depends on if you basically added the
widget and then removed it or so you try
to add more than one widget on same
screen you will expect all of the app
widgets that are currently on the screen
to be called when an update calls right
yes basically what I do on our widget is
go through all the array all
the time yeah matter how many instances
in check and update them all or you can
lock the feature for more than one
widget on screen and see if you have
another instance running of the up
widget and then just pop up the dialogue
to the user saying you cannot have more
than when we just were running on the
screen yeah yeah it's just the question
is implying that the documentation says
it may not bring up all the widget IDs
of all the current active widgets it may
just be a subset and maybe that would
happen it's worth checking sauce maybe
there's there is rate-limiting about how
often widgets can update so if you've
updated one recently force an update to
it then maybe it won't request the on
update during its cycle but I don't know
that for sure you have to check the code
all it's saying is that you're not
guaranteed to get the entire list of
currently active widgets i like you'll
see i always just go through the list
that I've got and assume the other ones
that need updating yeah Hugo says I have
a layer list drawable and I want to add
a line to the bottom of the drawable the
trouble is going to be scaled I can't
get the line to be at the bottom half of
the drawable only in the center any tips
lana storables they're not very well
documented are they so Chris start your
next code snippet no I'd have to look up
the lowly Straubel and play around with
it myself like you know I remember maybe
you could put a shape inside the
drawable that's the size of the entire
Torah ball but only has a bottom margin
or so you can't but line there is no
line shape so anyway well there's a
shape that you can't like Larry the bond
I think anyway you can do a draw but
it's both put in a rectangular and never
it type on top from what I remember so I
don't know well I don't look at that one
i Floyd see you there
it's not so you can hack together yeah
exactly ACO challenge
it sounds fun I always just play with
those ones until it looks like I want it
to look like I've used him a few times
and Dustin Evans at the very bottom of
the the G+ threat has asked for I was
wondering if anyone has any guides on Oh
Wharf tutorials for Android development
I've pretty much done the hello world
tutorials and would like to dive deeper
oh yeah we have to if you look at Google
Tasks and then go for the code samples
for Google Tasks is that Android code
sample that does include a wharf have
you done a few times we did a Google
Drive code lab that used OAuth you can
look for that we gave it at dev ops this
year and I'll try also giving you google
play services authentication as well if
I can cover your needs then that's
definitely the best way of doing it now
because you can just authenticate
against the Google account so have a
look but the the most commonly used
OAuth example is the Google Tasks one so
check out Google Tasks specifical grab
it quickly
yeah well it's quite old yeah all the
Play services we're not using so much
the auth methods for now because we're
getting the tokens
if you gave it the opposed on google.com
slash Google Apps tasks are tasks and
Android I'll post it on so on the G+
that was where I first figured out
Andrew Kelly's put a comment saying I
had a moderator question on fragments
that's the one I answered yeah yeah
Andrew didn't join in for the first few
minutes so maybe we didn't answer it
before entry joins us now in sit offline
so bear with us yeah
as we re moderate the question a
reminder had a questions a scenario
where he replaced his fragments so he
adds a fragment via XML and then
throughout his activity he replaced them
with other fragments and what he was
fond in was at the first fragment which
he's a DV XML wasn't being replaced so
it was actually removed it was still
stuck stuck there behind all the earth
fragments and so he wasn't getting the
on pause or I'm detached for you or
commonly of called exile and so he was
asking why why does this happen and and
T on T oh I don't know the reason why it
happens but I put a solution available
where he replaces the XML fragment tag
with a frame layout and actually adds
the first fragment in his uncreate it's
that way it will all keep afternoon as
before I am loop the sauce yet yes and
yeah unnamed is me sorry that I don't
and so yeah that's the STM solution I
can think of I haven't looked at the
source yet I never look after this of
the reasons why my guess is that the
view group which is a DV XML these
needed so it can be replaced moving the
activity but that's my guessing with
absolutely yeah
Etienne City works so sounds good and
I'm definitely any other questions yeah
we have one I remember seeing it
something about share action provider I
would like to have a custom share
provider looks like activity data model
hinders me quite a lot of doing this any
advice on doing it more easily have some
custom share provider hmm and then later
on what is action provider on prepare
submenu useful maybe you could put those
questions in the moderator for next week
I let you take a look at them really and
answer them formally jens you can wait
okay yeah thank you all very much for
joining us I think we'll cut it short
there at uh only ten minutes then he
won't we
not too bad time to drive for Android
he's gone